[Musique]
larry johnson et sa femme patricia sont
des catholiques convaincus
marié depuis près de 50 ans la rue a été
servants de messe membres de la chorale
de l'église
il a fréquenté des prêtres pendant toute
sa jeunesse à l'école primaire au
secondaire dans les équipes sportives
c'est à l'âge de 15 ans que la rive à
comprendre que les prêtres de son
entourage n'étaient pas tous des bons
gars ce jour-là son prof de latin et de
religion un homme sympathique avait
décidé de l'emmener seul dans sa voiture
au camp des frères augustin au bord d'un
lac
il était déjà allé à cet endroit avec
d'autres élèves à la fin de la journée
le prêtre enseignant propose de dormir
dans la région et de rentrer le
lendemain
larry ne se méfie pas l'adulte lui offre
de boire de l'alcool
beaucoup d'alcool le jeune larry est
coincé à 200 kilomètres de chez lui il
décide de rester debout aux aguets toute
la nuit et c'est lui qui prend le volant
au petit matin pour rentrer à chicago
la seule façon d'aller au fond de cette
histoire c'est de mettre sur pied une
véritable enquête gouvernementale
aux etats unis la pression populaire
exercée par les victimes de prêtres et
les groupes de défense qu'ils ont créée
a forcé les autorités publiques à mener
des enquêtes judiciaires à travers le
pays depuis qu'une enquête devant un
tribunal spécial a eu lieu
en pennsylvanie nous réclamons que les
procureurs généraux de chaque état
américain fasse de même
à ce jour 16 d'entre eux ont commencé à
tenir ce genre d'enquêté au moment où
nous avons débuté l'anc est ici en
illinois
les noms d'environ 150 prêtres et
membres du clergé catholique qui avait
pris part à des activités sexuelles
illégales avait déjà été divulguée
en tant que procureur général de
l'illinois lisa madigan a mené l'an
dernier une enquête approfondie sur les
abus sexuels de prêtres de son état et
l'a découvert que non pas 150 mais
plutôt 700 prêtres catholiques avaient
fait l'objet de plaintes au cours des
dernières décennies
les enquêtes judiciaires démontrait que
le clergé avait tout fait pour camoufler
ses abus sur des mineurs
le clergé fermer les yeux lorsqu'un
prêtre faisait l'objet d'une première
plainte ou encore si le prêtre avait
démissionné pendant qu est non plus si
le prêtre était décédé ou s'il avait
quitté le pays quand on ne me mets
aucune investigation si la victime
refusait de collaborer avec le clergé ou
si elle souhaitait conserver son
anonymat
larry hughes thompson s'est impliqué
dans l'organisme snap
il en est même devenu le directeur
régional pour l'illinois
il avait d'abord cherché à obtenir
justice mais le clergé lui avait fermé
la porte
larry n'a pas totalement coupé les ponts
avec l'église
malgré ce qu'il a vécu il lui arrive
même encore de célébrer des mariages en
tant que diacre de sa paroisse
malgré toutes les enquêtes un grand
nombre des cas d'abus sexuels de prêtres
ne sont jamais traduits en justice parce
que les auteurs de ces abus sont
aujourd'hui décédés les enfants victimes
aujourd'hui adultes demande des réformes
fondamentales aux membres du clergé qui
vont se réunir au vatican
[Musique]
peter slee a lui aussi cherché à obtenir
justice de la part du clergé
en vain il a découvert avec les années
que les penchants criminels de son
agresseur était connu et camouflé par
les autorités catholiques du conseil
pour lui le clergé n'est rien de moins
qu'une organisation criminelle qui
encourage les abus sexuels sur des
mineurs
en tant que porte parole d'un groupe de
pression
il aura l'occasion de s'adresser
directement au pape françois à la
conférence du vatican cette semaine
comme la plupart des milliers d'autres
victimes
larry antonsson ne cherche pas à obtenir
de compensation financière de la part du
clergé
il veut surtout que justice se soit
vendu au sein du clergé et dans la
société
[Musique]